hablamos ahora de economía en 324 y
estamos para eso compañera hablando que
nos va a contar lo más importante hoy
también la bienvenida
empezamos en eeuu que pagara todas sus
deudas con la organización mundial de la
salud muy buenas noches liliana pues
entre obligaciones atrasadas y actuales
washington él le debe a la o ms unos 200
millones de dólares pero lo
significativo no es tanto este monto
sino lo que implica el pago el
presidente yo bailé en lo que está es
concretando el reversazo a la decisión
de donald trump de retirarse del
organismo que muchas veces en fue blanco
de sus críticas este es un paso clave
hacia el cumplimiento de nuestras
obligaciones financieras como miembros
de la ms y refleja nuestro compromiso
renovado de garantizar que la oim s
tenga el apoyo que necesita para liderar
la respuesta mundial a la pandemia
incluso mientras trabajamos para
reformarla para el futuro y recordemos
liliana que el nuevo presidente de eeuu
no sólo se quedó en la omct también
prometió volver al acuerdo de parís para
luchar contra el cambio climático y que
fue firmado en 2000
variedad y en europa las ayudas
aerolíneas generaron controversia la
aerolínea irlandesa de bajo costo
ryanair se fue hasta los tribunales de
la comisión europea para protestar dice
que durante la pandemia se han otorgado
subsidios estatales por más de 30 mil
millones de dólares a las aerolíneas
bandera de la unión europea por la
pandemia pero no les tocó estos recursos
una de las medidas que molestó a ryanair
fue la del gobierno francés de diferir
el pago de impuestos a las aerolíneas
con licencia de operación en ese país y
también demandó el caso de suecia que
creó un sistema de garantías de
préstamos también para empresas con
licencia sueca
ryanair dijo que estas ayudas
distorsionan la igualdad de condiciones
el tribunal general de la unión europea
dijo en primera instancia que las ayudas
no son discriminatorias pero la firma
irlandesa apelará el fallo ante la
máxima autoridad que es el tribunal de
justicia
daniela y uruguay volvió a exportar
arroz orientemedio cuéntenos y señora en
2020 este pequeño país suramericano no
había
hacer envíos de arroz a oriente medio
pero acaba de obtener una licitación que
le asegura por lo menos el envío de 60
mil toneladas a irak
el gremio de productores dijo en su
cuenta de 'twitter' que esto se debe a
la calidad de producto a pesar de que
tiene unos precios más altos que sus
competidores en efecto entre sus
competencias están en los grandes países
asiáticos y en américa a otros como
argentina brasil paraguay y eeuu bueno y
el casino que fundó donald trump en
atlantic city quedó reducido a escombros
daniela el casino trump o plaza ubicado
en nueva yersey fue erigido como la joya
de la corona del imperio hotelero del
ex-presidente fue por varios años uno de
los sitios preferidos de las estrellas
de cine cantantes deportistas y famosos
en general para ir de fiesta pues este
miércoles bastaron apenas 20 segundos
para que se desmoronará la imponente
torre inaugurada en 1984 esto fue a
través de un
implosión controlar el deslumbrante
casino sin embargo ya no pertenecía al
ahora ex presidente porque en 2016 lo
había vendido al millonario carl icahn
por todas las deudas que acumulaba junto
con otro casino el taj mahal que ahora
opera bajo la marca hard rock hizo
demoliciones se hizo para obras
benéficas caridad pues tenemos ahora
cómo están los indicadores de la jornada
wall street de cerró en terreno mixto un
nuevo recorte para el índice dow jones
de industriales- las bolsas europeas se
cerraron a la baja los inversionistas
están refugiando en una atractiva
rentabilidad de la deuda pública de eeuu
y en américa latina hubo ganancias
generalizadas sobre todo en argentina y
la cita del día los 15 millones de
dólares que repartió el gobierno chino
entre 50.000 residentes de beijing esto
como parte de su programa de pruebas de
joanes digitales los residentes pudieron
gastar este dinero virtual entre el 10 y
el 17 de febrero en ciertas tiendas o
plataformas de comercio electrónico
el one digital lo quieren usar para
impresionar a los asistentes de los
juegos olímpicos de invierno en 2022
esta es una manera a liliana de
incursionar oficialmente en las
polémicas monedas virtuales que están
circulando hoy en día sin la mediación
de las autoridades económicas gracias
daniela por la información de colombia y
a usted gracias por estar en france 24
recuerden que pueden visitar nuestra
página web france24 puntocom nos vemos
más adelante
[Música]